prière de rester dehors dans cette
petite salle du centre ville seul les
assesseurs était autorisée pour le
dépouillement quasiment tous équipés de
masques et de gants le point final d'une
journée d'élection très particulière on
a déjà eu un taux d'abstention plus
important aux dernières municipales
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on a mis en
oeuvre toutes les mesures d'hygiène et
de sécurité pour garantir ce scrutin
démocratique et je pense que voilà le
dépouillement s'est bien passé seulement
35 % de participation soit plus de 20
points de moins qu'en 2014
le maire sortant françois rebsamen
arrive logiquement en tête à la sortie
des urnes il est en ballottage très
favorable
emmanuel bichot arrive lui en deuxième
position tout sourire il frôle les 20%
même si c'est le moins bon score de la
droite à dijon l'a certainement
bénéficié dans les derniers jours d'une
prime d'une prime au sortant lié à cette
crise sanitaire mais pas dans des
proportions qui le remettent au nid à
son niveau de 2014 où il avait fait plus
de 44% au premier tour en revanche nous
nous apparaissons avec 19 +19 et demi
pour cent comme la seule alternative
les verts effet tête de liste et fanny
mode sont bien la troisième force
politique à dijon avec 15 % ils
prendront part à une triangulaire
est ce que le second tour va être
maintenue pas maintenu en tout cas moi
je demande vraiment comme au niveau
national le lv demande vraiment à ce que
le président fasse au plus vite
l'annoncé du maintien au poste de second
tour en sachant qu'on est aussi sur un
confinement qui serait prévu donc ça va
être vraiment très très compliqué
la république en marche autour des 9 et
le rn a fait ne verront pas ce deuxième
tour pour ces deux parties c'est un
véritable échec